[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد دوامه العنف
والعنف المضاد في تركيا وايران وسوريا لن
تتوقف مهما طال الزمن وتنوعت الاسلحه
ومستوياتها دونما حل حقيقي للقضيه الكرديه
في هذه البلدان وفقا لما يراه الكاتب
والبحث السياسي كفاح محمود في مقاله
الاخير موضحا ان درس العراق هو الاكثر
فائده لها لاختصار الطريق الذي لو استمر
ستبقى هذه الدول غير مستقره ينخر فيهما
الصراع الدموي ويسرع في انهيارهما اجلا ام
عاجلا ويقول الكاتب بان الدستور الذي
صاغه الساسه العراقيون عربا وقردا وبقيه
المكونات كفيله النظام الفيدرالي معترفا
بفداراليه كردستان بكافه مؤسساتها
وتشريعاتها جعل حل القضيه الكرديه في
العراق تجربه تجربه يحتذى بها لحالتك
الاشكاليه التي انتجت اتفاقيه سايكس بيكو
في كل من تركيا وايران وسوريا
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيفنا من اربيل
الكاتب والباحثه السياسي كفاح محمود كاتب
هذا المقال وكذلك يشاركنا في النقاش من
اسطنبول المحلل السياسي التركي يلماز اهلا
بكمين واسم حالي ان ابدا بكاتب هذا المقال
وفي الواقع صياغه بعض الجمل اتت صريحه
ولكن ااه يعني هناك خضه الصحه التعبير
لانك لما تقول استاذ كفاح بان لسوريا ولا
تركيا ولا ايران ستتمكن من تحقيق السلم ان
لم تعتمد معتمده العراق باختصار كيف ذلك
في صراعها مع الاكراد اتحدث طبعا
نعم نعم بدايه مساء الخير استاذه ريما
عليك وعلى زميل الضعيف من من تركيا
انا لم افرض الحل العراقي ولكنني قلت بانه
التجربه تجربه نموذجيه يحتذى بها
وعلى ال ال الاخوه يعني دول الجوار التي
تعاني من هذه الاشكاليه اشكاليه المكونات
الاكبر هو المكون الكردي في كل من ايران
وتركيا وسوريا همم عليهم ان يستفيدوا من
التجربه العراقيه خاصه وان يعني كل
الاسلحه التي استخدمتها الانظمه العراقيه
من ثلاثينيات القرن الماضي او ربما حتى
حتى قبل ذلك قبل تاسيس المملكه العراقيه
ايام الحكم العثماني ايام في يعني في
بدايات الق- القرن الماضي بانتفاضه الشيخ
عبد السلام البارزاني الذي اعدمته سلطات
العثمانيه انذاك في مدينه الموصل مركز
ولايه الموصل في وقتها
وحتى 2003 و 2005 وشرعنت الدستور العراقي
الجديد وتحويل العراق بالنظام شمولي
معقد الى نظام نظام فيدرالي يعترف
بفيدراليه كردستان وانتهى انتهت صفحه
دمويه في تاريخ العراق ذهب ضحيتها سيدتي
ريم مئات الالاف من الكره العرب في
الانفال واحد قتلت السلطات العراقيه 188
الف مدنيين من الاطفال والنساء والشيوخ
والى اخره لاهيك عن ضحايا ال- ال- القصف
الكيميائي اعود الى تركيا وسوريا وايران
الاتراك يعانون اشكاليه كبيره يعني ليس
فقط من يقتل من حزب العمال كل سنه هناك
ايضا الاف من ال- من الجنود الاتراك قتلوا
ثكلت امهاتهم وترمله نسائهم وتيتمت
افعالهم يعني الماسات مشتركه
اكثر صحيح ولكن حتى افهم منك اكثر
وباختصار لو سمحت ليه حتى انقل الكلمه
للاستاذيه الماس النموذج العراقي نجح في
استيعاب الاكراد او نجح في تمكين العراق
من حكم ذاتي
تمكين الاكراد
سيدتي الكريم البدايه كان في عام 1970
ايام حكم
الرئيس احمد حسن البكر في حينها وحزب
البعد تحديدا حينما اتفق الحزبين يعني
الحركه التحرر الكرديه والحكومه العراقيه
على اول اتفاق لمنح الكرد حتى الحكم
الذاتي فعلا تم التطبيق الحكم ذاته ولو
كان هناك مع اخذ من الحركه القوميه
الكرديه عليهم لكن كان هناك حكما ذاتيا من
ناحيه الدستوريه تم تطويره في 2005 الى 92
حينما استقلت كردستان ذاتيا بصدور قرار
مجلس الامن 688 اصدر برلمان كردستان قانون
الفيدراليه
وتشر على هذا القانون في همم 2005 حينما
مشروع
العراق في تجربته مع الاكراد لان ضيف يقول
لا تركيا ولا ايران ولا سوريا يمكن ان
تعيش بسلام اذا لم يكن هناك حل جذري موجود
للاكراد
تحيه طيبه لكم ولجميع المشاهدين الكرام
سيده الكريمه لماذا ندفع النموذج العراقي
وتركيا دوله ديمقراطيه وانا مع حصول
اخواننا واشقائنا الاكراد جميع حقوقهم في
ظل الدوله التركيه الموحده
المشكله ليست مع الاكراد في الحقيقه
المشكله مع الارهاب وهناك استغلال طبعا
للعنصريه وللقوميه هذا من جانب من جانب
الاخر هل حقيقه نجحت ال النموذج العراقي
يعني هل رضي اخواننا الاكراد لحكم الذات
ام توجهه نعم نحوه تقسيم العراق لولا
الجهد التركيه العراقيه المشتركه لكانت
اراك تنقسم وتنفصل هذا الاقليم قبل عده
سنوات
نسينا هذا هذه المساعي هل هذه تجربه
المطلوب كرديه هل المطلوب تقسيم البلدان
لان فيها مكون كردي و و
وتاسيس دوله كرديه كبيره على الاراضي
التركيه الصحيه التاريخيه
معك
همم يعني قدم الموضوع من الاخر يقول لك
بان هذا الصراع سيبقى موجود وسيبقى ازلي
لان الحلم موجود وهم يدافعون على ذلك همم
تكوين دوله مستقله فقال بانه العراق تخطط
هذه العقده ومكانته من حكم ذاتي بينما
تركيا في المقابل هي تعيش باكراد الداخل
وتحاول كذلك ابعاد اتراك الخارج نتحدث على
الشمال السوري
السيده الكريمه هل
سيبقى العراق هكذا يعني هل يرضى الاكراد
في العراق على الحكم الذاتي ام يطالبون
لدوله مستقله يعني نحدد قبل كل شيء هذه
الاشكاليه يعني ثانيا من يقول ان هناك
مشكله كورد صحيحه حصلت مشاكل صحيح صحيح
اخواننا للاكراد عانوا همم من مشاكل صحيح
ولكن تركيا مع ترسيخ منطقه الديمقراطيه
همم ينال اخواننا الاعراض الاكراد جميع
حقوقهم وهم همم لهم احزاب همم لهم وزاره
يعني نستحي نخجل ان نتحدث بهذا الشكل
لانهم يعني صعبه البطل لا هم جميع حقوق
دون التفريق المشكله كما قلت ليست مع
الاقراض المشكله مع التنظيم الارهابي
تستغل اا العنصر الكردي يعني همم عندما
يستغل تنظيم داعش الدين الاسلام او هل
يعني مشكلاتنا مع الاسلام ام مع تنظيم
داعش كمثال هذا تركيا مشكلتها مع الارهاب
وليست مع الاكراد
والاكرا الصاحب الوطن هناك اكثر من 10
ملايين في تركيا
عن الاكراد وهكذا يقول مراقبون هي همم تصف
اكراد الحدود على الجانب السوري
بالارهابيين وحتى اكراد داخل في بعض
التصريحات همم السياسيه كذلك اتت في نفس
هذا السياق
يعني هذه مشكله عندما
الزميل الزميل يلمس طبعا
كل التقدير له
واحتراما لرايه ايضا انا لا انكر بانه
هناك نظام ديمقراطي ولكن هناك تحفظ ايضا
على سلوك هذه هذه هذه
الديمقراطيه هناك ارخص اخرى همم تقف او
لها راي اخر في الديمقراطيه التركيه وانا
لا اقصد هنا الكورد بل حتى معارضين من
الاتراك همم هناك مئات الالاف في السجون
يعني همم اخي المازي همم يعرف لماذا بصرف
النظر ان كانوا انقلابيين او كانوا
معارضين او كانوا لديهم اراء اخرى عموما
ليس هناك نظام ديمقراطي متكامل في الشرق
الاوسط مع جل احترامي للتجربه التركيه
وحتى التجربه العراقيه نحن ما نزار رغم
هذا التراكم من سنوات في مرحله الحب
والديمقراطي عموما همم اكرر بانه مساله
اتهام معارضيهم بالارهابيين وربطه هذه
داعش من يلتهم صحابيين في حزب العمال
قاتلوا داعش في كوباني وقاتلوا داعش في
الرقه وقاتلوا داعش في سوريا وكانوا ابا
اي ربما اكثر من تركيا قاتلوا داعش
وحافظوا على سقوط سوريا
بيد داعش وحرروا عاصمه داعش في في في
سوريا الرقه همم
اعتلام التي لديه اشكاليه مع المكونات
لديها اجنده اتهام اتهام الكرد في في
اراضيها او على ارضهم بانهم ارهابيين
وعملاء كما تفعل اي الان ايران تنتحمهم
تاره بانهم عملاء الموساد والمخابرات
الامريكيه وانهم ارهابيين وو الى اخره
وتصدر ازمتها الخانقه في ايران تصدرها الى
اقليم كردستان كما تفعل تركيا ايضا اؤكد
بالاخ الى الماج بان التجربه الكرديه هنا
في كردستان لا تفرف هذه الصيغه على اكراد
ايران ولا على اكراد تركيا بالعكسيه على
خلاف يعرف نحن على خلاف حاد جدا مع حزب
العمال الكردستاني وصل الحمد الاقتتال مع
ال- مع البيشمركه في كثير من ال- ال-
القواطع في شمال الاقليم وكذا الحال مع
كثير من الحته المعارضه الايرانيه
ولاهيك عن الخلافات مع الاذرع الموجوده في
في المناطق الكرديه في سوريا لكن القضيه
الكرديه قضيه حساسه وهذه انا اعتقد بعض
القضيه بعد القضيه الفلسطينيه في الشرق
الاوسط هي اخطر القضايا التي تواجه الشرق
الاوسط عموما يعني ليست تركيا فقط والعراق
بين تركيا والعراق وسوريه وايران والدول
المجاوره جميعها لانه هذه النار ما لم ما
لم تطفى بعقلانيه وبياهما بمياه بارده
ساسه تنتشر و ستحرق الجميع اليوم همم
تصدير مثل هذه الازمات واستخدام السلاح
انا قلت دعوه يعني يستفيدون من التجربه
العراقيه لا الاسلحه الكيميائيه ولا
الانفال ولا قتل الناس ولا قتل الجماعي
استطاع ان ان يسقط حركه التحرر القدس
الثانيه اتهامات بغداد كانت تتهم الحركه
التحرر الكرديه بانهم ارهابيين وانفصاليين
وعملائي اسرائيل وعملاء الامبرياليه وكذا
الحال في الدعايه التركيه والايرانيه
والسوريه هذه لن تنتج شيء هذه اشياء غير
منتجه دعونا نفكر بهدوء كيف نحل هذه
الاشكاليه بعقليه ديموقراطيه كما تفضل اخي
الماس نتمنى جميعا ان تكون دولنا بمستوى
المواطنه الجامعه دون ان يتسيد العنصر في
اول عربي او الايراني لكي نحل هذه
الاشكاليه وننتهي حتى بدون فيدراليه
كذلك فقد خليني انقل استاذ كفاح الكلمه
الاستاذيه المصري لانه همم هناك مجموعه
كبيره من النقاط في الواقع اتيت عليها من
اهمها بانه القضيه الكرديه هي قضيه تاتي
حتى ااه بعد القضيه الفلسطينيه مباشره
البعض حتى استاذ ريال مصر يستذكر القضيه
الارمنيه يقول بان هناك مخاوف بان يكرر
التاريخ نفسه وتكرر تركيا ما فعلته مع
الارمن ان تكرره مع الاكراد همم فهل يمكن
ان تكون لتركيا او ان تغير فتراتجيتها
تجاه هذه القضيه تعتقد
النحج اللي خلطه الامور بعضها ببعض القضيه
اليمنيه شيء اخر والمشاكل الاكراد شيء اخر
وكانت هناك اقتطال اصلا بين الاكراد
والارمل وتدخلت الدوله العثمانيه في ظروف
الحرب العالميه الاولى لابعاد لنقل
المواطنين من مكان الى ما كان هذه قضيه
يعني اخرى اما بالنسبه الاكراد من يكون
انا لست ضد ان ينال الاكراد جميع حقوقكم
دون الاستثناء في ظل الدوله الديمقراطيه
التامه انا ما ضيفك الكريم ان قد تكون
هناك انتقاد انتقالات ونقص في الديمقراطيه
التركيه ولكن يجب العمل على ترسيخ هذه
الديمقراطيه لتكون هناك يعني مواطنه
مساويه جامعه ينال الكل حقوقهم بدلا من
همم من همم من تقسيم الدوله الى حكومه
الذاتي غير ذاته ومن لماذا لا يكون الحال
في ظل الدوله همم
كامله الديمقراطيه همم دوله وطنيه موحده
همم ديمقراطيه الكل ينال حقوقه دون
التمييز همم
للاساس هركي او ديني عن طريق
ذلك فقط جمله تفريق بين الاحزاب السياسيه
بين السياسه والاحزاب السياسيه وبين
الجماعه المسلحه
طيفكم الكريم تحدث كان هذا التنظيم
المساله لا يريد ان صفه
ماذا يقول يعني هل يقبل التمرد المسلح
عليها
يجب التمييز هو هو
تركيا ليست
رعب
العلاقات الجيده بين التركماني لكردستان
الوقت الخاص
السياسي كفاح محمود شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]